- So some are accusing Trump
lawyer Michael van der Veen
of stealing coasters
from the Senate floor.
Let's watch.
Yeah, he seems to be taking some coasters.
Though, we don't actually see him
walk away with the coasters.
Yeah, I mean, arguably
he's taking some coasters,
but those coasters are there to be taken.
They're disposable.
And come on, if you're a
lawyer on the Senate floor,
arguing your case in front of the country,
I think you deserve some
souvenirs to take home,
some Senate embroidered coasters.
I think that's okay.
The Trump lawyers did a lot
that deserves criticism,
but taking a handful of
coasters home as souvenirs,
probably not one of them.
But of course I would
say that, I'm a lawyer.
And speaking of which, subscribe
or I'll see you in court.